Lastly, today we'll talk about subsurface materials
and parallax control.
So here we'll talk about creating a subsurface material,
which we'll use Jade in this instance.
We'll talk about using parallax occlusion mapping
with material functions.
We'll talk about creating some ice
and how you may go about doing that.
I will talk about the subsurface profile in Unreal
and then also give you some pro tips to close out here.
So there's a few things to consider
if we're thinking about creating subsurface materials
and this instance, like we said,
we're going to use the example of Jade-like material.
So creating something like Jade or even ice,
you can make some dependencies
to make the material rich with control.
So you have plenty of control for your artists
to really dial in the effects that they're wanting to use.
So we set up the material to be a subsurface
under the shaded model.
So when you have your material open,
you want to make sure you're not clicking on any nodes.
You can click on the main root node
that you can see in the bottom of the image here,
but essentially you'll see this on the details panel
in your material.
So you just want to change the shading model
to subsurface to texturize the effect.
Color can be stacked with lerps and multiplies
to get the desired results.
So that's exactly what you can see here.
We've got two color values.
We're lerping, which is the linear interpolate
between this noise-based texture,
which then multiplying based on the amount that you want.
And you're making parameters of all these properties
so that you can dial them in
either in your material parameter collection,
like you said before, that you saw before,
or whether you just want it
on a per material instance basis.
So the final texture output can have a scaler on it
to control the amount of noise filter to use.
So this is plugged into the lerp.
So you can see the amount of noise here,
which is the noise being multiplied.
And this is the point that we're talking about here
just before the end result.
If you want to control the opacity
of a subsurface material,
you can create a Fresnel index
and control the exponent there.
So you introduce a lerp and a scaler
to control the subsurface amount,
which is the opacity that is used
for the transmission here.
And then also you can add a multiply into this lerp B
to then multiply the subsurface amount effect.
So it can be adjusted with a new input,
but it can be used as a generic range control
in this instance.
To add subsurface control,
we create a Fresnel node as well, again,
and then this helps sell the idea
of some kind of light affecting the surface.
It gives it that rim light and look.
You could create a scaler for the exponent.
And in this case, it controls the edge subsurface control.
And then you can also create a scaler
for the specular reflection.
In this case, it'll give the illusion of thickness.
So plug that into the base reflection fraction in,
and then you can also plug in a multiplier
with a cons three vector to control the overall color.
So a few notes here
that when we're adding subsurface control,
the Fresnel that is found under the vector ops
is a highly customized version of the Fresnel.
So that allows you to affect many different aspects
of how the Fresnel is rendered.
So you can see the properties here.
There's great documentation on this.
This image is taken from the documentation.
So they allow you to dial in the Fresnel values
that you're looking for.
This is the Fresnel node,
but just to know that it can give more control,
but it can lead to artifacts if not set up correctly.
So only use Fresnel, the regular Fresnel,
if this version isn't getting the results that you want,
and also if you don't understand
some of the properties found there.
If we're looking at parallax occlusion mapping,
so the parallax occlusion and material function node,
we use it to simulate a 3D effect.
So it's like a bump offset, but with more visual accuracy.
So no real distance limitations.
It is expensive.
The visualize will not calculate correctly,
so it will stay green appearing to be safe.
So when you're looking at your view render modes
and you're looking at how expensive this might be,
it appears safe, but it does have a lot of complexity
to it, as you can see with the complexity of the material.
So material collection is the shadows
and the light source reaction are more realistic
at an angle than a bump offset.
So it can save on needed geometry.
This sample shows parallax UVs plugged into each text
UV for the shift effect, but you
can see the kind of pros and cons of each approach here.
Sometimes, especially with the newer features of Unreal
Engine, say, Nanite approach, you
may just want to add the geometry in there.
And especially if you're doing anything with virtual
reality, the VR will break any kind
of illusion of a bump offset or a parallax occlusion.
So again, it depends on the project outcome.
You want to weigh up the optimization
versus the end visual result for the user or the player
or whoever it is that you're creating this project for.
But hopefully, that gives you an idea
about how you might use parallax occlusion mapping
inside of your projects.
Continuing with the parallax occlusion mapping,
temporal AA can be used to jitter
the number of rays slightly.
It causes traces to be out of phase
and cancels out artifacts over time.
And shadows can be adjusted manually
and might need to be for accuracy.
And it must be activated in the function.
So again, just keeping in mind this performance
versus visual fidelity payoff.
This approach with the shadowing can be expensive
or it will be expensive, should I say.
So the pixel depth offset can also be added
for accurate intersections.
If other geometry is introduced,
the flatter the surface, the better in this instance.
And then just a note here before we wrap up,
if a height map is introduced,
steep maps will have noticeable stretching.
So to fix this, you can have a world alignment texture
that can be used for tiling options or troubled areas.
And then for creating your ice effect.
For ice, you can use a world alignment material function
that can be introduced to help
with subsurface, visual matching.
The world alignment textures help
for textures to be consistent and matching
and not based on UVs,
but world position for the subsurface.
And then with a Fresnel node and a subsurface color,
they can be plugged in into that subsurface node.
So you can see an example
of exactly what we're looking at there.
The subsurface profile,
which you can get through right clicking
in your content browser, going to materials
and the subsurface profile is here.
So the subsurface scouting profile data
is an asset that can be created,
shared because it's a data asset
and saved in the content browser.
So the data is intended to be authored by artists
and controls the distance,
the light and the subsurface should scatter.
It controls the color of the subsurface
and also the fall off color of the light
once it has exited the object.
So the data can then be applied to a subsurface material
and then the subsurface profile data
can be tweaked interactively,
meaning that you do not need to recompile the material
to see the end results.
So it's just a nice global way of really dialing in
what it is you want to do.
And you can add it into the details panel
of the material here with the shading model.
You can just use a subsurface profile
and then add that subsurface profile into here.
So it really gives you a nice global feel
to what it is you're looking for.
You may have them map specific, for example,
to really dial in that visual effects
of the subsurface in a given level.
So it can be created and loaded into the material
and also migrated into different projects.
If you want to keep reusing your subsurface profiles,
has a separate menu,
as you can see in the bottom right here,
updates without compiling, as we said,
and it's still not visually robust
with the customization of apparent material.
Few pro tips to close out then.
So it's best to customize your subsurface material
with full control of the properties, like you can see here.
So you really want to dial in,
you want to make sure everything's some kind of parameter
that you can really hone in the colors
and the values that you're aiming for,
as well as any maps that you want to include.
Mega scans export or plugin material creation.
A transmission effect is not as strong
as customizing the subsurface material.
And you also want to create as much customization
as you can for best control
and results for an instant material.
So as we usually do at the end of these sections,
you can find subsurface profile and documentation here,
and also just information about how to use subsurface
in your Unreal Engine materials
at this documentation page here.